welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and Marvel's the Eternals is coming
early in phase four and now that we have
some first looks at its production we
are starting to put together why this
film could be the key to Marvel's future
no not just as a distraction forget
Herrington to pretend that the final
season of Game of Thrones never happened
blinking these new images with recent
discoveries made from spider-man far
from home we might have just figured out
how the MCU will use the Eternals to
establish mutants living among us I'm
gonna break down everything we know
about the Eternals in this episode of
explained okay so recently we've seen
some leaked set photos from the Eternals
production directed by Chloe Zhou
showing what appears to be an
archeological dig and ancient ruins
featuring what looks like Babylonian
Mayan and Egyptian architecture this
reflects the little that we have been
told about the Eternals that it will be
a story that spans thousands of years
filling in the Marvel historical
timeline of ancient eras on earth now a
bit of history about the Eternals they
are immortal beings created by these
Celestials now we have seen the
Celestials in the MCU before there was
East on the searcher from the collectors
story who wiped out a planet with the
Power Stone and ego the Living Planet
star Lords father was also established
as a celestial Celestials like these
came to earth and ancient times and
conducted genetic experiments on the DNA
of the unev almonds that they found
there through the Homo erectus form
resulting in two genetic offshoots one
was the Eternals the immortal beans with
superpowers basically Marvel's version
of the New Gods and the other was the
evil deviants millennia later Thanos was
born with that deviant gene which might
explain his frequent appearances on
deviantart ass the Eternals cast
includes Richard Madden Robb Stark from
Game of Thrones as the eternal Icarus
and Jemma Chan previously played the
Kree Minerva and Captain Marvel as
Cersei Icarus and Cersei have a romantic
relationship something that
screenwriters Matthew and Ryan Firpo
suggested would play a role in the
film's plot but more on that in a sec
also in this eternals lineup is Salma
Hayek as a Jack the leader of the
Eternals Angelina Jolie as the warrior
thena
Kumail Nanjiani as Kingo Bryan Tyree
Henry as Fastow's lauren riddle off the
first deaf superhero in the MCU as the
speedster Macari Lea McHugh has sprite
an eternal stuck in the body of a child
Don Lee is the powerful Gilgamesh
and Barry Cogan as the new character
drug Marvel head Kevin Feige showed off
the whole lineup in concept art for what
their characters will look like at d23
but the most surprising announcement for
that panel was that Kit Harington would
also be joining this cast not as an
eternal but as the character Dayne
Whitman who in Marvel Comics is one of
the people who take on the mantle of the
hero Black Knight Black Knight is
warrior who wields the ebony blade a
sword forged from a meets your and
blessed by Merlin that protects the user
from harm Black Knight is essentially a
hero title passed down through the ages
with origins and Arthurian legend kind
of like how Thor was based in Norse
mythology so what the hell is Black
Knight doing in a film about the
Eternals where are they going with
giving kitt a sword with some actual
mythological payoff well according to
Feige the Eternals is all about quotes
this notion of all these myths and
legends that we know from ancient times
were they inspired by the Eternals
actually spider-man apart from home had
a line that hinted at a similar concept
from a scene that we should rewatch very
closely the science division had a
technical name we just called them
elementals versions of them exists
across our mythologies turns out the
myths are real like Thor Laura was a
medicine now I study him in my physics
class now there was a lot of lying going
on here Mysterio's monsters weren't real
modern incarnations of mythological
figures they were fictional projections
and all the research from Nick Fury and
Maria Hill was actually coming from
Skrull shapeshifters in disguise trust
nothing in this film actually trust
nothing ever you're in the matrix but
they projected the imagery that we see
in that scene of various mythological
figures is from real human history you
can see there are images from the Greek
sea god Poseidon along with what looks
like Greek mythological sea dragons
maybe like the skill ax of the Titan
there are fire entities perhaps based on
Mayan folklore or the Greek figure
Hephaestus there are also winged statues
perhaps based on figures from Egyptian
mythology
Feige suggestion for Eternals implies
that all of these myths are linked to
the characters were about to meet in the
Eternals film Fastow's is linked with
hephestos also Faustian or Faust from
the German folklore referring to a deal
with the devil
Icarus is based on the famous winged
figure Icarus from Greek mythology who
flew too close to the Sun and melted his
wings peel
in real-world history was the king of
the Sumerian city-state aruch in the
hero of the famous Mesopotamian
mythological poem the set photos show
archaeological dig sites uncovering
ruins from all of these myths and one of
those myths could be the legend of King
Arthur which is how Dane Wittman could
come into this story actually in the
Marvel Comics Wittman Black Knight has a
love affair with Cersei in a story that
ends up telepathically linking the two
of them so they essentially share a mind
that could be what we see in this
eternal film with Kit Harington as
Whitman a modern archaeologists
exploring ruins discovering the ebony
blade and finding himself blast into an
ancient past we has a love affair with
Jimmy chance Cersei and Harrington's
Game of Thrones brother vigor Richard
Madden Icarus all while in the backdrop
there's an ancient war between the
Eternals of the deviants that could set
up a future deviant gene Titan to seek
the Infinity stones but also could set
up the biggest game changer to hit the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the mutants as
you may have seen in the well not great
x-men apocalypse film the mutant villain
apocalypse was one of the earliest
mutants in history dating back to
ancient Egypt and many believe that
biblical texts were actually based on
that godlike mutant in the Marvel Comics
during the Celestials experimentation
with early humans they also left
embedded in certain humans what was
later defined as the mutant gene a gene
that results in superhuman abilities to
manifest at certain ages and under
certain environmental conditions
therefore the origin of the Eternals in
the origin of the mutants are
intertwined
and this Eternals movie and telling us
the history of the immortal protectors
of Earth could also establish the
existence of individuals across earth
with this unique genetic makeup some
whose mutant gene is still dormant maybe
some who have just existed in secret
this whole time maybe even knowing that
the MCU Celestials had access to
Infinity stones those stones could have
been part of the process that created
all of these beings so that the recent
use of Infinity stones by Thanos Hulk in
Tony Stark uses that rocket described as
having a shockwave effect could have
awakened this mutant gene and that's how
we get x-men now in the MCU this would
be a discovery made by MCU John Snow who
still went around in some of the places
and Peter Parker's physics homework
finds the sword that turns him into a
Yankee in King Arthur's Court and then
maybe jumping back even further day in
ship babylon to link his brain with
gemma Chan and pissed-off the previous
king of the north all so that we can get
Keanu as Wolverine in a few years that
is Marvel's internals explained how do
you think the mutants will be introduced
in the MCU comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram on
twitter at your boss and subscribe to
new rock stars or explanations of all
the Marvel stuff that you might not care
about yet but it will soon dominate your
life thank you for joining me and you
can now return to sexy Thanos
[Music]